[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge ein hof am
see silvia und marcus burg suchen die
ruhe in schweden
sie vermieten dort ferienhäuser viva
méxico stefan ohl odeon stefano
navarrete zog es in die karibik im land
ist die kita wittern sie ihre chance und
familie zogaj möchte sich in südafrika
neu erfinden
sie eröffnen eine lodge
[Musik]
doch heiß hatten sich entschieden
vor wenigen wochen haben sie den
kaufvertrag für ihr haus unterschrieben
so eine wie sie große reisetasche so
einige nette was weiß ich ja gar nicht
mehr hergestellt an
heute wollen sie zum ersten mal wieder
in den eigenen betten schlafen
das haus liegt in einem dorf mit 4000
einwohnern und wenn endlich lauf schon
mal über dieses land aber ist dass
chocolat
das ist schon cool aber ich war an die
stange
nein nein anders
mehr als ein halbes jahr hat die familie
gesucht
endlich angekommen
[Musik]
in der letzten folge verschoben torkreis
ihre pläne vom neuen leben in südafrika
einmal mehr und dann entdeckten sie
ihren platz in mexiko inspizierte onkel
fernando die baustelle an der casa
italia und der phänologie macht der
weiteres kapital flüssig schreiner
markus kämpfte in snuko mit schwedischen
möbel acht wochen schuftete markus fast
rund um die uhr
jetzt sind die zwei ferienhäuser der
burg fertig
[Musik]
die erste nacht war kurz die talks
staaten in ihren neuen alltag
die beiden kinder müssen zur schule
das morgen fällt aus für mika und seine
schwester annika der schulbus wartet
nicht
50 kilometer sind es bis zur haltestelle
des schulbusses eine gute halbe stunde
sind sie unterwegs ab sofort jeden
morgen die kinder gehen weiter in
hermanus auf die schule
dort können mika und annika einen
international anerkannten abschluss
machen
interferenzen und einwohner
eine vergleichbare schule gibt es in der
nähe von napier nicht
treffpunkt in stanford und fast
pünktlich aber egal jetzt mit dem bus
noch weitere 20 kilometer bis zur schule
abends das ganze wieder zurück fast zwei
stunden schule blick jeden tag
[Musik]
sommer in schweden
freiburgs stehen bald neue rollen
aufgaben an
aber markus stürzt sich erstmal wieder
in die arbeit und das ein borusse fahrer
kann weil unter der wasseroberfläche ist
eine recht viel schilf das ist ja
unangenehm und da mal dass ein
schwedischer darf schilf abnehme machen
schöne badeplatz gegessen schalter ja
sehr meditative arbeit aber wenn sie
morgen welt ist
[Gelächter]
silvia und markus haben ihre gesamten
ersparnisse und die pensionskassen
gelder in das neue zuhause investiert
lange waren sie nicht im grundbuch als
eigentümer eingetragen
bis sie rechtlich abgesichert waren hat
es 14 monate gedauert
das hat silvia mehr belastet als sie
dachte dass mehr dass sein können nach
auf endlich ist alles geregelt
auch das geschäft mit den beiden
ferienhäusern ist angelaufen
bis ende der saison sind die unterkünfte
bereits ausgebucht ich könnte man sagen
auf die wesentlichen dinge konzentrieren
unterhalb von vor allen dingen
geburtsvorbereitung ist allerdings kurz
vor dem letztlich ein paar wochen ja
also ich habe meine letzte woche er
bücher lese wie ich was tapezieren oder
welchen wasser aus schluss machen ist
der bücher wie ich noch als kind
wirklich sollte kann ich mich damit
beschäftige
aber es macht schon nervös wenn man
irgendwie nicht so ganz haben wir pro
scan ich mach die bahnhof fertig und
komme
[Applaus]
[Musik]
noch gut drei tage zeit bis zum
errechneten geburtstermin
[Musik]
die riviera maya ein ferien traum in der
karibik millionen von touristen kommen
jedes jahr hierher und es werden immer
mehr
[Musik]
überall wird gebaut alle versprechen
sich schnelle renditen auf stefano
navarrete und stefano lotti wollen hier
investieren und setzen dabei auf einen
neuen geschäftspartner
[Musik]
marco bellocchio ist immobilienberater
er kommt aus italien und lebt schon
einige jahre in mexiko
[Musik]
manche
marco sucht ständig neuer investoren mit
den schweizern und ihrem kapital hoffte
er auf größere projekte und auf neue
kunden
sind die familie kein engländer so sieht
es der mutter und dann bin ich mit denen
sprechen sie den von rom sind und wenn
ich morgens in step by step stunden
geöffnet wie viel fleisch hat überhaupt
so viel gutmachen
die vistamar agentur junge band aus noch
kontrahenten
[Musik]
die drei haben bereits eine firma
gegründet
sie bieten ihre dienste als makler an
aber sie wollen auch luxuriöse
ferienwohnungen kaufen und diese
vermieten
so rechnen sie mit einer rendite von 8
bis 13 prozent im jahr
da kann das bisherige geschäft mit onkel
fernando nicht mithalten
unter dieben qualitätssprung machen und
qualitätssprung muss man natürlich mit
geschäftspartner machen wo dauert
möglichkeit gab sondern seine nächste
level zu erreichen
seinen job bei onkel fernando hat
stefano gekündigt die wohnungen in der
casa italia haben sie an ihn verkauft
und sie haben sich vom onkel ihren
anteil auszahlen lassen an dance jene
suite appartements
grundsätzliche der wälder dass ich als
nachfolger von hier aber für mich immer
klar sehen dass ich das mit dem staff
von ein bis zwei geburtstage ziel
darum haben wir das projekt sah man
startet erfolgreich beendet und jetzt
sind wir uns einfach neu orientieren und
das ist einfach wirtschaftlich also mir
hat es immer noch gut miteinander
verdanken dass der situation ist wo alle
hilft belag auch bieterin sie nicht
schaffte machen und das soll nicht
heißen dass man uns madame jahren habe
ich auch das hat mein fleisch und
knochen liegt beim selbermachen und
schlussendlich meter nach oben schaffte
zum geldmachen zum sünder onkel fernanda
war hilfreich für den start jetzt freuen
sich die fans mehr
[Musik]
nach vorne auf die mountainbikes aus der
schweiz sind heiß ganzer stolz einen
teil der zwölf velos wollen sie an gäste
vermietet den umzug machen sie diesmal
selbst das spart geld
gibson hilft beim zügeln freunde haben
ihn als mitarbeiter empfohlen einen
container voller hausrat 75 kubikmeter
haben die türkei aus dem thurgau
mitgebracht
viele setzen will dann muss er die
steine die schweiz clown gibson hier
noch was das ist hier öffnet bevor das
objekt ihrer haft als waffen seien alle
einig wo david sasaki klose
das löste waren böse
[Musik]
vor dem kauf hatten timo und doris das
haus genau unter die lupe genommen
aber der schlechte zustand der
wasserleitungen ist ihnen so nicht
aufgefallen
[Musik]
jetzt muss schnell ein fachmann her wo
andere models bei also den staat
phänomenal ist neu in meiner hand
[Musik]
für die burg in schweden steht
ungewohntes auf dem plan
[Musik]
a
heute nicht arbeiten
[Musik]
ab sofort thema offizieller woche
offiziell regelt aber halt mit mehr
freizeit wie die letzten paar wochen
[Musik]
nichts ja
markus und silvia auf dem weg in die
neue selbständigkeit und endlich haben
die beiden auch wieder mehr zeit
füreinander
[Musik]
kindisch und da weiß man nicht so recht
zu verhelfen und die schneemänner freund
gelangt dass die sprache bringt freude
bewirkt
das ist jetzt da los ist das ist okay
das ganze aufstocken wird
noch ist alles ruhig bei silvia und dem
baby eine freu mich drauf als gestern
davor kamen sind jetzt die lizenz
weitergehen kann und jetzt schon mal
selber platz für jemanden mehr im
prinzip wie ein viel zu viel erlebt aber
zierte für für die geburt haben kurz
längst einen platz im spital reserviert
in smoke blow auf dem hof sind beide
ferienhäuser vermietet
seit einigen wochen machen hier immer
wieder gäste aus der schweiz ferien
[Musik]
kiprop sind zum grillieren verabredet
klopf klopf mit dorothee und michael aus
dem kanton luzern
[Musik]
ich will
die gastgeber als gäste auch in diese
rolle müssen die bugs hineinwachsen
[Musik]
in südafrika checkt tibor wie groß der
schaden ist der schlauch aus dem wasser
gesprudelt ist ist nicht nur an der
außenwand defekt die schweizer haben dem
vorherigen besitzer vertraut dass das
haus technisch in ordnung ist und haben
auf einen schriftlichen nachweis sich
[Applaus]
christa nickel machen
da wird der gerade weil zuschauer
gekostet
[Musik]
klempner stiewe nicht lokale fachmann
installations
der klempner dichtet heute nur das loch
in ein paar wochen macht er dann die
komplette installation neu
[Musik]
es geht los ungewohnte hektik bei den
bobs in schweden und jetzige wie möglich
bieten apotheken sich alles sehr schnell
gegangen hat es noch nie
jetzt kann es sein dass es sehr schnell
geht und die ersten wehen einsetzten
markus muss mit silvia nach westerweg
bis ins spital sind es 60 kilometer
mindestens eine stunde sind sie
unterwegs
[Musik]
schließlich liegt überrascht
komme ich bin mega happy feet ist aber
freuen uns dass es losgeht
ich habe marco herbel nur zum zugucken
verdammt
[Musik]
während der fahrt sollte silvia leben
das hat ihr die hebamme empfohlen die
nabelschnur könnte sonst eingeklemmt
werden
[Musik]
die bugs auf dem weg in ihr neues leben
zu trinkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
streng bewachter luxus in playa del
carmen werden an jeder ecke ferien
unterkünfte gebaut
eines der projekte das marco mit den
beiden auswanderern aufgetan hat hier
könnten die baselbieter er geld
investieren
[Applaus]
stefanos stefanou besichtigen eine
musterwohnung sie bietet platz für zwei
personen und kostet rund 130 tausend
franken
die jungs wollen insgesamt sechs
appartements in unterschiedlichen
liegenschaften erwerben
alle mit luxuriöser ausstattung
[Gelächter]
das ist normales bett mit einer matratze
mache sinn weil die schlacht jedoch
begleitet atmosphäre der pc richter
zwei bis 300 franken miete pro nacht
erhoffen sie sich während der hochsaison
weit mehr als in der casa italia von
onkel fernanda haben ist mir waren durch
die liga stiegen weil alles andere ist
eigentlich viel schwieriger zu
vermarkten
es war bis dahin der stroh und verkauft
sich und formierten sich sicher besser
meint lage ist selbst sehr wichtig
wenn alles fertig ist wird die
apartmentanlage wie ein hotel betrieben
fitness club und pool auf dem dach
inklusive
das alles nur wenige hundert meter vom
karibischen meer entfernt
das know-how und die kontakte von marco
sind für die auswanderer nützlich für
den einstieg in den luxus
immobilienmarkt in playa del kann ich
bescheiden
er sagt ich will zeigen mit junge frau
als romantisch des islams ist aber im
schaftliche ist es für mich als
schweizer so lala
mit dem neuen geschäftspartner an ihrer
seite wurden die beiden stefano wieder
mal durchstarten
[Musik]
kiste um kiste die talks räumen ihrer
letzten sachen aus der villa in stanford
acht monate haben sie hier zur miete
gewohnt
mehr als ein dutzend mal mussten sie hin
und her fahren zwischen stanford und
mädchen für strecken hat tibor zwei
arbeiter angeheuert
die frau stieg günstig sind es ist soja
geschlechtslos gibt es eine neue nz
zuletzt muss das ganze haus geputzt
werden
für die übergabe ein schock für
haushaltshilfe handele
heute ist ihr letzter arbeitstag der
immobilie nachfolge
da ist doch lisa sich alle vertraut
verkehren auf der ganzen familie und mir
hat immerhin ein jobvermittler dass sie
wieder gute jobs sind rar
jeder vierte südafrikaner ist arbeitslos
einer der beiden mitarbeiter hat es sich
ein paar minuten hingesetzt
stanley fühlte sich nicht wohl
er musste pause machen
doris stein die scheibe schlecht wurde
zwar gelangen
das finde ich ja ich weiß
darin einig dass er als gelernter
torwart ingenieur dass gott da sein die
dies ins kühlfach gibt es ein
navigationsgerät das ok das noch
entgehen kann uns am set
[Musik]
töchterchen jona ist da und ihn snuko
wird alles anders
wir wünschen euch einen guten start als
familie und mir
[Musik]
markus ist die erste nacht nach der
geburt im spital geblieben im
familienzimmer bei ehefrau sylvia und
töchterchen juni also das erste mal das
ist ein wirkliches gefühl eine situation
wo man sich vorstellt wie sie sie wird
aber wenn es sie trifft dann ist sie
alles andere wie wir alles was du dir
vorstellen dass ich so emotionalen
mustermann yahoo und dann die erste zwei
esslöffel und ein kaputtes glaube markus
und sylvia wünschten sich schon lange
ein kind
dreimal gab es komplikationen jetzt hat
es endlich geklappt kleinen der
amerikaner ist unfassbar
also
es ist genial ist es so du siehst du
siehst es am fernseher oder und eine
dokumentation aber wenn es die eigene
tochter ist da nicht irgendwas der
irgendwie so ein zwei stunden lang
cheerleader coach physiotherapeut mit
dieser frau und er macht gerade kein
moment
[Musik]
solange silvia im wochenbett liegt
schmeißt markus den hof allein das
kleine ferienhaus muss hergerichtet
werden morgen kommen die nächsten gäste
waren vorne die leute blau gezogen bis
bezogen
zur sicherheit hat sie ja alles notiert
selbst reicht den blau gestreiften dann
bleibt vorne blau weißen sofa ein
komischer ca
markus will so schnell wie möglich
zurück ins spital zu seinen beiden
frauen
[Musik]
in playa del carmen machen die beiden
stefano nägel mit köpfen sie kaufen zwei
luxus wohnungen ohne finanzierung durch
eine bank das geld dafür hatte es der
phänologie in der schweiz flüssig
gemacht er konnte ihre liegenschaft dort
abstoßen
aber toll ist wenn man schon dass ich
einfach gute investition weil es auf die
perfect place ist wirklich vom zentrum
im zentrum was die meisten liegt also
das könnte zu lincolns langfristigste
bashmet
[Musik]
die wohnungen in strandnähe wurden sie
vorerst nur vermieden
aber irgendwann wollen sie selber land
kaufen und darauf bauen
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt stehen die
talker ist noch ganz am anfang
in vier monaten wollen sie ihre lodge
eröffnen
die gesamte anlage muss hergerichtet
werden die handwerker geben sich die
klinke in die hand
die talk heiß müssen alle zimmer
streichen lassen
das bad sanieren und die
wasserinstallationen erneuern
ich arbeite aber mit reserve das x fache
alles jahr zweiter hinter zu klicken und
mallorca was passiert also mich am ende
wirklich geld verdienen
der finanzielle druck ist termine
einhalten
verlässliche handwerker finden denn
ablauf organisieren
das kostet nerven und vor allem
[Musik]
fünf stunden hat mega sehnsucht
herzlich darüber hitzig aber ist ich
freue mich mega draufgesetzt
markus zieht es ins spital nach
westerweg zu frau und kind die beiden
müssen noch eine weitere nacht im spital
bleiben bis es mit dem stillen klappt
und sylvia sich etwas erholt hat
[Musik]
jona dreieinhalb kilo schwer
51 cm gross einen tag alte wurzeln
[Musik]
der neue mittelpunkt jona die lang
ersehnte
wo man für die letzten acht gestanden
die seen kunde ist anstrengend gebot ist
ja doch
rund 24 stunden gegangen außerdem müssen
sie gut begründet moment glaube den
kräutern
[Musik]
denn es schafft
[Gelächter]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
die group müssen sich in den neuen
alltag als familie einfinden
[Musik]
wohngemeinschaft leben bei den stefanos
mit oskar traditionell sie macht es
gerade und das muss auch und big
business mit dem neuen geschäftspartner
leon
[Musik]
stress beid en kreis in südafrika die
ganze linie sind gemacht
sie eröffnen ihrer lodge aber teile der
dekoration fehlen
neben
[Musik]
sid
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vor